one of the main situations that's
plaguing the United States right now is
depression how many people just look in
the mirror are not happy with themselves
so this is a little bit selfish one of
the things that I'm breaking out of my
show is from Pat
encourage you you need to be a leader
you need to have a family you need to
have a kids I'd be a great father I want
that in my life but right now I've been
very selfish rightfully so I'm on that
90 10 path 80 20 path no doubt Myron
yeah but at some point
um these selfish list needs to wane and
being selfless needs to increase and uh
if you don't look in the mirror you're
not happy with yourself you're not like
as much as you want to make other people
happy you can't make everybody happy if
you're not happy yourself 100